when you guys are separated you and your
wife and you are on the road is it
easier if you turn on TV and see her
or is it harder does it make that that
might L watch I stay away from the TV
you stay away I'll tell you the truth
like and it's it's tough because when I
did Game of Thrones my dog III didn't
want my wife to see it ya know she lived
with us my I mean not on the she lived
is my our kids were with me yeah my wife
was with me she knew the whole cast and
crew I didn't want to see it I didn't
want to do anything but we went to the
Burger supposed to go to the premiers to
be the first two episodes I'm like nah
now I'm not sitting around a bunch of
people what no no I'm not going so we
didn't go she's like you're not gonna
stop me from watching it I'm like
whatever the DVD comes out we don't even
watch it when I'm TV so we did I didn't
watch the whole series the DVD gets sent
to us from HBO yeah say I'm watching
like great a little bit going to bed I
wake up at 6:00 a.m. of my wife is
sitting over me but I'm just like hey
Bobe she was like you're amazing
she's like you were like first time I
went forever told me I was amazing and
she was just so proud to stay up all
night much little thing really and was
obsessed she freaked and I was like uh
and now like if I know a little thing
like I say I'm hanging out with like
Rory like the Hound yeah hey baby it's
just a [ __ ] look at me nothing real get
him like I know anyways yeah if I were
one of mess with her yeah like oh you
want to know what happened see someone
like Oh amazing
let her help me so but I know she's
kicking ass shoes on ray Donovan doing
but you know what the hard thing is I'm
like I just it's hard I don't really
want to see what's real things know I
would be the same I'm just like I I love
her it's our job yeah I got it that's
just my side going like I love you I'm
so proud of you I want to see it
everyone's so stoked and I'm like and
I'm feel bad but I same time I'm like I
didn't want her to see that yeah I
necessarily want to see that yeah fair
enough
yeah but right I watch a couple scenes
yeah so proud of her um she's back in it
that's it's great I'm sure you you saw
and heard from fans with their reaction
to the trailer for Justice League what
was your reaction to
trailer house like this Aquaman
propaganda yeah it was amazing right I
was Zack Zack is just he's I love him to
death man is amazing and he's been
obviously it's his vision yeah pulled me
into play it he believed in me you know
changed my life you know God oh I
already got a lot and stuff that he
thought and just seeing the trailer I
was like wow yeah because everything
that I brought and wanted to bring it's
all the hopes that you want to bring to
you character he made sure that stuff's
there when you originally heard that did
you think that they were going to make
it cut your hair off and bleed your
blonde chicks a lot hears a lot of
things once in my day there's a lot of
things that'll do by mine and I was like
because I was thinking like Lobo yeah I
was like yeah I'm gonna play some kind
of bad guy I'm like yeah Who am I gonna
write and yeah he said I'll come in I
was just like come again excuse me
yeah pardon me and then in the knee
explain why yeah I was like for buddy
and you know what that's your back you
know what this is like when you get
involved in those things you see what
you see with all the other actors where
you say yes once and suddenly that world
could be your world for the next ten
years no that's a big does that factor
into the commitment to jump in and do
something like Aquaman just like the
commitment of life that this thing may
take it's the ups and downs you know me
yeah we're constantly unemployed as
actors sure it's never nothing is ever
certain but yeah I mean I signed on this
four or five years ago
yeah and then now it's you know now we
finished just Justice League it's like
wow it's awesome yeah I know I'm going
to do an Aquaman and I'm here you know
you hope you make the right decision and
I'm like I can't wait
Yeah right wait the kissing scenes
underwater are they hard very [ __ ]